on va parler de santé à présent dans le
7 8 avec cette annonce faite il y a un
mois la NSM l'Agence nationale de la
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé à donner un avis favorable à
l'entreprise Sky thérapeutique c'est ce
pour le lancement d'une première étude
clinique sur la myopathie de Duchenne on
en parle avec notre nouvelle invité
c'est Louis Garcia bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes directeur de recherche au CNRS
conseillé scientifique de ce qui a été
thérapeutique je vais être même le
co-fondateur de cette entreprise basée à
50 ans en Yvelines et qui est d'ailleurs
même hébergé au sein de l'UFR santé
Simone Veil de l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on le précise
une entreprise qui a été créée en 2015
qu'est-ce que Sky thérapeutique en
quelques mots ce qui a été thérapeutique
c'est un peu une aventure au départ
c'est une aventure elle a été fondée par
des parents des parents de patients de
malades atteints de la myopathie du
chêne par des chercheurs des cliniciens
également tout ce petit monde s'est
retrouvé ici à l'UFR santé à l'occasion
de la création de notre unité de
recherche en 79 Inserm
UVSQ et puis dans la foulée on a créé
cette société avec pour objectif de
créer des médicaments parce que la
recherche on en fait très bien à
l'université mais l'université n'est pas
destinée c'est pas sa mission de
fabriquer du médicament pour ça il
fallait une entité un peu spécifique de
type biotech et c'est ce qui a été
thérapeutique qui a pris ce flambeau
avec la volonté de l'ancré sur le
territoire c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle sky on a la bannière Skywest
juste derrière on est sur Skype
le médicament était conçu fabriqué
développé
produit en partie et sera testé sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin aussi
puisque le lycée clinique aura lieu à
l'hôpital de Garches qui dépend de l'UFR
santé donc on reste sur sur ce
territoire on va parler de cet essai
dans un instant juste sur la myopathie
du chêne précisée qu'elle touche 150 à
200 garçons nouveau-nés en France
environ 2500 personnes en sont affectées
par cette maladie génétique rare
qu'est-ce que la myopathie de Duchêne
qu'elles en sont les causes et quelles
conséquences ça entraîne sur sur le
malade alors c'est une maladie
emblématique vous avez dit le nombre en
fait un garçon sur 3500 3000 selon les
chiffres 50 pas tout à fait à la
naissance d'accord donc ça veut dire
compte tenu du nombre de naissances en
France on divise par deux filles garçons
ça fait à peu près deux nouveaux cas par
semaine donc c'est un peu comme au loto
sachant que tout le monde ne joue pas
mais il y a que les femmes qui ont des
enfants donc c'est une maladie quand
même rare mais c'est parmi les maladies
rares c'est la plus fréquente d'accord
et elle touche les enfants dès l'âge de
2-3 ans et c'est une maladie évolutive
donc c'est elle est emblématique pour ça
parce que à partir de 2-3 ans les
enfants des difficultés à marcher ils
perdent ambulation vers l'âge de 8-10
ans en général parfois 12 ans puis après
ça s'aggrave c'est une maladie on
connaît bien le quand j'ai commencé
d'ailleurs c'était une maladie
strictement pédiatrique aujourd'hui on a
de jeunes adultes on a de jeunes gens
maintenant atteint la maladie donc il y
a eu des progrès dans la prise en charge
mais ça reste quand même des des cas
avec des des handicaps très très lourds
et la maladie connue maintenant depuis
un siècle et demi c'est du chêne de
Boulogne qui avait identifié au milieu
du 19e mais on n'a toujours pas de
médicaments beaucoup d'essai cliniques
beaucoup de promesses on espère que nous
ce sera une réussite mais pour le moment
on ne peut que promettre
c'est des maladies génétiques c'est des
mutations dans un gène particulier qui
est localisé sur le chromosomix le gène
de la dystrophie on a donné le nom de la
maladie à ce gène et c'est en fait c'est
une protéine qui joue un peu le rôle
comme d'un amortisseur d'accord entre la
membrane et l'intérieur de la fibre
musculaire et donc ça amortisse ça fait
des tas de transition de signaux il y a
d'autres fonctions mais on imagine très
bien que d'amortisseur quand cette
protéine n'est pas là l'amortisseur
n'est pas là ça colle partout ça se
déchire ça s'abîme et en fait les
garçons ont simplement en marchant en
jouant détruisent leur muscles et donc
peut-être on espère une bonne nouvelle
dans la lutte contre cette maladie
puisque je le disais ce qui a été
thérapeutique ça a reçu la vie favorable
de l'ANSM pour son étude clinique avance
1 cela consiste à administrer chez
l'homme le composé ou parliez de ce
médicament Sky 51 qu'est-ce que ce
composé qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
observer justement avec cette étude
qu'est-ce que vous allez observer alors
ce composé un c'est un peu singulier le
rationnel thérapeutique derrière est
connu depuis une vingtaine d'années
c'est ce qu'on appelle le saut d'exon on
a beaucoup parlé sur les plateaux télé
tous les ans au mois de décembre ça
c'est ce qui est particulier là
singulier là c'est que c'est une
nouvelle chimie c'est la première fois
que cette chimie va qu'on va exposer des
êtres humains à cette chimique les
tricyclosna un peu de l'ADN un peu
bricolé et donc pour ça ce qu'on appelle
ça un First Newman firsting Man et ça
c'est une première c'est une première
aussi parce qu'en France on a eu des
essais cliniques on a des essais
cliniques sur cette myopathie mais
souvent c'est des phases 2 ou des phases
3 c'est des phases extensions là c'est
un premier médicament qui est synthétisé
sur nos territoires et c'est sur un
territoire avec une technologie de notre
territoire ça c'est le fruit de l'unité
de recherche thérapeutique c'est et
voilà d'un collectif je vais pas tout
seul on est il y a 20 ans de personnes
qui travaillent sur sur ce projet et
voilà c'est une histoire collective
alors ce médicament c'est ce qu'on
appelle un oligonucléotide ça ressemble
à de l'ADN c'est tout petit c'est 15 du
kiotiques 15 bases le génome il y a des
milliards de base 15 bases et on les
injecte en systémique c'est-à-dire dans
un vaisseau sanguin ça va aller un peu
partout
et ça va accrocher le gène malade au fur
et à mesure qu'il est
transcrit en ARN pour faire la protéine
manquante on peut pas le faire parce
qu'il est muté il m'a dit génétique ce
petit truc va s'accrocher à un endroit
bien spécifique on a calculé un peu
comme un anticorps comme un vaccin et
réparer localement provoquer une
réparation et le garçon parce que seuls
les garçons sont éteints de cette
maladie parce que c'est sur le
chromosomique pourront produire une
protéine qu'on dit semi fonctionnelle
c'est pas la protéine normale elle est
quand même fonctionnelle et on espère
que ça va marcher et l'idéal c'est
d'arrêter la progression de la maladie
pour les plus jeunes qui ne rentrent pas
dans la maladie et on va dire pour les
plus grands les plus âgés ben en tout
cas les stabilisés et avoir une
amélioration on verra on verra de
calordre elle est on peut rien remettre
pour le moment mais de toute façon
contre cette maladie du chêne Régine
justement pour cette essais clinique
combien de patients allez-vous inclure
dans cette et ses clinique et comment
est-ce que vous allez les sélectionner
en même temps de l'annonce de cet avis
favorable vous avez annoncé aussi le
recrutement de patient alors il s'agit
d'un essai à faire Slimane donc c'est de
la première étape la phase 1 donc on va
se focaliser sur la sécurité avant tout
donc le ça va être une progression avec
une escalade de dose et on prend une
corde relativement petite une douzaine
de patients 12 patients adultes enfant
quel que soit l'état ce qui compte et
être malade avec cette maladie et d'être
éligible à ce médicament parce que c'est
un peu un médicament à la carte c'est un
peu comme un vaccin on a un vaccin
contre le covid un vaccin contre la
grippe c'est de vaccins mais ça vaccine
pas contre les mêmes choses sky51 Sky
c'est nous qui le faisons c'est pour ça
que ça s'appelle Sky 51 c'est contre
l'exon 51 de la dystrophine il y aura un
exonc 16 un exemple 44 et 53 par la
suite mais c'est c'est de la médecine
personnalisée en fait donc tous les
patients ne sont pas concernés
malheureusement par ce médicament seul
10 à 15% des patients avec des mutations
compatibles avec notre médicament
et combien de temps va durer cet essai
alors la phase 1 va durer pour chaque
passion à peu près 3 mois une escalade
de dos celui 15 jours et puis ensuite on
demandera une prolongation en phase 2A
après autorisation par la NSM pour la si
tout se passe bien évidemment ou là ça
durera encore 6 mois donc l'un dans
l'autre
l'essai pour chaque patient durant un an
donc ça veut dire que si c'est concluant
on pourrait le voir sur le marché dans
combien de temps c'est plus compliqué
parce que il faut ensuite une phase de B
une phase 3 etc il y a peut-être si ça
marche si c'est spectaculaire on peut
espérer que ce soit avant si c'est moins
spectaculaire ça prend dans le temps que
ça prend fond du temps mais nous notre
objectif parce qu'encore une fois je
l'ai dit au début
la société est pilotée c'est la volonté
de parents
l'objectif c'est pas simplement de
vendre c'est surtout de proposer aux
malades quelque chose qui fonctionne
avec soit bientôt les ré et qui soit
efficace et on a le temps pour nous dans
le sens où on ne s'arrêtera pas sur un
échec c'est-à-dire si jamais on voit des
problèmes on reculera un peu on
arrangera et on reviendra donc c'est pas
c'est pas un aller simple et ça marche
ça marche pas merci en tout cas d'être
venu en parler sur ce plateau Luis
Garcia de cette avis favorable et donc
l'essai clinique qui va débuter pour
skyte thérapeutique autour de cette
maladie de du chêne je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur de recherche au
scénariste cofondateur de cette
entreprise Sky thérapeutique merci
d'avoir été avec beaucoup